qué diferencia hay entre el movimiento y
la vida cuál es la diferencia entre esta
sonrisa mecánica y esta sonrisa amistosa
es un poco difícil de definir pero hay
algo especial en el movimiento de un ser
vivo y aquí en pixar trabajamos
arduamente para capturarlo con nuestros
personajes ese algo comienza con una
etapa que llamamos a articulación hola
me llamo brian greene soy director
técnico de articulación en pixar la
articulación es el proceso de agregar
controles a un modelo digital que
permiten a los animadores desplazar el
modelo y hacerlo actuar si observas cómo
se mueven los seres vivos notarás que
cada uno de sus movimientos causan una
reacción en las demás partes de su
cuerpo por ejemplo cuando sonrío no sólo
se mueven mis labios mis mejillas se
abomba en la piel que se encuentra
alrededor de mis ojos se arruga mi
barbilla se estira para adaptarse al
movimiento esto es lo que llamamos
deformación y desplazamiento para la
articulación tenemos una caja de
herramientas con diversos de formadores
que podemos fijar a la malla superficial
de los personajes y todas ellas
representan fórmulas matemáticas y
definen la relación entre los muchos
puntos que se ven afectados
por el movimiento por ejemplo puedo
empezar a articular la boca de sol y al
agregar un simple de formador llamado
rota aquí la base matemática es la
trigonometría voy a agregar otra
herramienta llamada repulsión
básicamente esta herramienta infla y
desinfla cosas al agregarla a las
mejillas y enlazarlas cuando movemos su
mandíbula esta se abomba así está mejor
pero aún sólo es el principio la cara de
sol y por sí misma usa más de 500 de
informadores y eso es solo su cara
podemos seguir un procedimiento similar
para articular partes del cuerpo de los
personajes usando de formadores que
definan la relación entre rodillas y
pantorrillas la cola y el trasero o este
tentáculo y este otro tentáculo ya que
se establece correctamente su fisiología
tenemos que recordar que estos
personajes son actores de cine es decir
el tipo de movimiento que tengan que
hacer pueden ser un poco más extremo que
el de un monstruo normal entonces lo
exageramos un poco les da más vida así
pueden parecer super emocionantes en
pantalla